you're a very popular comedian you got
an email from a fan recently and you
posted it and I just it it caught my
attention as it would anyone let's see
this here I just want to say thank you
you don't know if it was something you
said the son of your voice or the
bartender's drinks but my wife of 24
years after me in the parking garage
before we left the mall after your
Sunday night show in Columbus Ohio is a
question
what are you doing at your shows that's
the kind of that goes down in my
shows man
like if you come to my show you were
gonna have sex at the mall or a parking
lot somewhere like that's just the kind
I can't give it away but everyone always
has sex at my shows that's the greatest
ad for a show I've ever heard yeah yeah
yeah yeah I mean it's not necessarily a
mall but there is there are places where
there's nothing more I can see if you
want to have sex in a mall or a parking
lot you can go see Tom live October 26th
in Fresno California I throw em Saroyan
theater October 27th in Bakersfield
California at the Fox Theater and like I
say I think you're gonna get lucky yeah
yeah Tom Segura oh he's great
[Applause]
you